foreign
[Music]
whatever
[Music]
happened
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
whatever
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
quack
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
welcome everybody Welcome week 11 six
bets we love
before we get started though before we
get started before we get to the
nitty-gritty there's a game guys there's
a game that's going on today in Detroit
it's not going on in Buffalo but it is
going on in Detroit
but I want to talk about the lying
movement on the over under well I'm
moving on over under
I think it got it it got as low as 41
because of the climate in Buffalo they
you know they thought the game was going
to be played in Buffalo but they moved
to Detroit and now it's sitting at 50.
guys Sam Ryan talk to me how we feeling
about that one
uh well first I'm just bummed that we
should be preparing for a beautiful snow
game that just feels just so right this
time of year and the fact that we're not
getting it uh hurts my soul but no I
mean it it checks out right like 41
points would have been tough to get to
when you're playing under six feet of
snow in Devin singletary's five seven so
um making making the move to a dome is
definitely a huge difference but it is
interesting I think the spread is
actually kind of interesting too because
um just of like this is now playing
played at a neutral site instead of at
home and it really hasn't moved that
much which I think again speaks to sort
of the weather and just how that would
have impacted the game but uh but yeah
pretty pretty bummed over the snow game
yeah Ryan
yeah that I would have really liked to
bet on a Snow Game that would have been
so much fun I do think it would be
hilarious though if this game covered
the original like if the under hit on
the original 41 that would be very funny
to me like 35 3 bills like I could
definitely see that that would be
hysterical
a shout out to uh everybody that caught
the over 41 when it was like you know at
41 yeah and now it's like 50 but anyway
hey let's get to the nitty gritty you
guys welcome everybody that is watching
I gotta introduce my friends my name is
Greg Aubrey next to me is this man the
myth the legend Sam Richmond and next to
him is the guy that connects us to you
producer Ryan but you guys know why
we're here y'all know exactly why we're
here we're here because Sam was giving
out his six Best Bets and if you guys
ain't been paying attention y'all need
to start paying attention because my man
I call him the man the myth the legend
for a reason my man's been going crazy
this year so drop your locks in the chat
we'll be grading your picks at the end
of the show Ryan
we're going to send you back we're going
to send you back to the chat we'll see
you later Sam brother
I mean we already asked you how we
feeling I like the background like the
sweatshirt love the hat backwards seems
like you're feeling good seems like the
Vibes are flowing can we get 45 seconds
on the clock please my man Sam he he's
true that he's 45 seconds he will stick
to these 45 seconds uh but can we get 45
seconds on the clock please there's the
45 seconds is Sam you know what to do
take it away brother
all right this one's gonna be tough to
fit into 45 seconds because I really
love this pick today and I don't think
you like it so we might have some debate
but I really like the Cowboys today
Cowboys money line is my first pick of
the day to me this is just a great Buy
Low sell High spot the Vikings coming
off this massive win the Packers coming
off just a brutal blowing the game to
the Packers they're going to be super
fired up to sort of right that wrong and
then when you just sort of get in the
actual football side of things like I
truly believe the Cowboys are the better
team here clip that out
um yes the what the Vikings did last
week was really impressive it doesn't
change the fact that they just have a
totally unsustainable record in one
score games they're 17th in dboa the
Cowboys are fourth I had to sneak that
in there since I'm running out of here
but I really really like the Cowboys
today
Sam big bvoa guy big bvoa guys Sam
Richmond uh hey Sam you know I I mean I
don't dislike your pick I mean you know
I think that this one's going to be a
shootout but you do know Minnesota's
playing at home right
I do I I think the Cowboys are
significantly better I like I still
again what the Vikings did last week was
really impressive to me it doesn't erase
the first 10 weeks of the Season where I
think they've really kind of gotten very
lucky they've been out gained in a lot
of games again they've won seven
straight games by one possession to me
those are sort of coin flip games and if
three of those coin flips go the other
way and they're sitting at six and four
I think we're having a completely
different discussion
hey I know who's I know who's happy
about this pick Sam I know somebody
who's happier producer Ryan come on in
here come on in here because uh I know
you're probably smiling right now I love
this pick I love this pic Sam he's
probably smelling right now producer
Ryan loves this pick but talk to us
about the audience do they like the pig
anything else the audience doesn't like
the pick but do we care Sam no uh
j23 cash says I'll be at the game
Minnesota wins Vikings plus the points
uh Z McDowell says I think this is when
Minnesota gets exposed uh Maddie 2x
Vikings do for an L uh so we are getting
some positivity here uh chance of
lightning though says y'all trying to
get people to lose money Vikes by seven
disagree hard to say a chance of
lightning where are you from because
that's going to tell us everything about
that comment if you're from Minnesota
sounds a little biased but uh hey Ryan
we're going to send you back to the chat
appreciate your time brother
Sam let's get back to business we got
one down five more to go
this is why the people's here so let's
get to it 45 seconds on the clock
please
45 seconds is on the clock Sam take it
away
all right next pick also going to be
very unpopular which is just a trend but
I am taking the Lions plus three if
you've watched this show you probably
know that I am just not a believer in
this New York Giants team I continue to
think they're they're pretty below
average and that sort of again backed by
the metrics that I care about they're
ranked 19th in dvoa
um and their defense is really in the
bottom tier of the league and I just
like how the Lions been playing you know
they've won two in a row that lost three
weeks ago it was a really close loss
against the Dolphins that offense went
humming I think can really expose this
poverty Giants defense so I'm you know
I'm gonna continue fading the Giants I I
don't think they should be three-point
favorites uh right now and uh I think
there's a real chance that this team
ends up missing too
there it is Sam says he's rocking with
the Lions Sam I don't have much pushback
I don't have much push back and lines or
getting healthy or getting healthy uh I
like the points man I like the points
let's talk about the next one that's two
that's two those at home look at the
right like look at the right side of
your screen that means that's two beds
down 45 seconds is on the clock Sam we
need four more picks talk to us brother
and Jeff Saturday we trust man Colts
Colts plus six and a half
um look I think you know I think it's
it's scary but on this cold scene that
has looked pretty bad for most of the
year but I was really encouraged by what
they did last week in terms of running
the ball especially again when you
consider the matchup this week the
Eagles are a great team no doubt they
are vulnerable against the ground game
we saw the commanders just completely
control that game and if the Colts
offensive line is playing even halfway
to what we expected them to be is coming
into the year which they did look like
last week and Jonathan Taylor's healthy
I think the Colts have a real chance to
slow this game down grind it out they're
not gonna win but six and a half points
at home is a lot in this league so I
really like ND today
there it is and he left some time on the
clock Indy's at home they're at home Sam
mentioned in Jeff Saturday we trust all
we need is a close game all we looking
for is I like that Sam I like that one a
lot uh that's three now we're halfway
there
we got three more to go
but this is why the people are here so
we're just gonna get right to it Sam 45
seconds is on the clock let's go
all right I like this one a lot too I'm
taking the Steelers plus four anytime
you take the Steelers in a spot like
this I'm obligated to say that like Mike
Tomlin is 9003 against the spread in his
career as a as a home Underdog Ryan
don't fact check me there but it's got
to be something pretty close to that but
yeah I mean this is Steelers have been
great in these spots and yes their
statistical profile isn't great but this
defense is a whole different animal and
TJ watt is back in the lineup we even
saw that last week
um getting him back Minka Fitzpatrick is
on track to play uh and I'm just not
really a big believer in this Bingo
steam especially without Jamar Chase
yeah they were able to put it to the
poverty Panthers but that offense really
hasn't looked the same without Chase so
I think the Steelers and a spot that
they've traditionally been really good
cover here at home
there it is the buzzer has sounded Sam
Stealers are at home
it's hard to beat that Pittsburgh
Steelers divisional matchup those games
are always really close Four Points I I
really like them today
not yet they battled last week too uh
but it's it's hard to beat that Steelers
team in Pittsburgh uh let's tap in with
producer Ryan let's tap it with producer
Ryan we're four picks in
we need to know what the people are
saying are we getting Good Vibes
are we getting bad vibes because you
know what we do to those bad vibes we
turn bad vibes into Good Vibes what's
the temperature check in the chat
sometimes I turn bad pipes into good
fives it depends how I'm feeling uh Sam
I didn't listen to you I did fact check
you Mike Tomlin is fourteen four and two
against the spread as a home Underdog
13-7 outright uh over the past five
seasons though he's 70-2 against a
spread as a home Underdog I mean there
it is it has it lost
Ryan Scoops that is what that is that's
a scoop right there it is all right
let's get to the chat uh my guide to
onions back in here uh love the Detroit
pick against uh the Giants the Giants
are gonna get exposed uh I totally agree
uh J nodges says below average referring
to your take about the Giants Giants
defense gotta hand the Lions their ass
the Lions May hand the Giants their
kneecaps though so what's more value
yeah what's more valuable uh mudface
says he loves that Colts pick which is
surprising because I feel like the Colts
have gotten nothing but Flack from uh
the public since the Jeff Saturday
hiring uh and then
we've got Kings Co says them picks
looking good the chat is is they are
pretty uncharacteristically positive I
love that yeah I was honestly just under
the assumption that you were just like
filtering out every 10 bad comments and
reading the good ones but yeah
that's good yeah you know you know I'll
feature the haters okay see I'm honestly
looking at your four picks and I'm like
man this looks like a juicy parlay this
looks like a real juicy parlay but
fear not because
no I'm just kidding it's a four teamer
right now we potentially could make you
guys a 16. Sam has given the six Best
Bets we're four bets in we got two more
left can I get 45 seconds on the clock
producer Ryan we're gonna send you back
to the chat brother uh Sam
take it away
all right I am taking the Chargers plus
five and a half
um I people are really down on the
Chargers right now which I get they're
offense didn't move the ball at all last
week and has really been struggling but
to me I think the explanation for that
is very obvious Herbert hasn't had
anyone to throw to today he's expected
to get not only Mike Williams back but
Keenan Allen back and that to me is a
total Game Changer and again these
divisional matchups they are typically
close especially between these two teams
the Chargers and Chiefs have played very
very close matchups together and I you
know to me this is like the charger
Super Bowl every time they play the
Chiefs this is the team that they're
trying to measure theirselves against
that they need to beat so I think
they're super motivated so five and a
half points at home Herbert getting his
weapons back I like them to keep this a
close game
there it is my man rocking with the Los
Angeles Chargers plus five and a half I
I don't dislike this one like you said
those matchups are always close
Justin Herbert's getting his weapons
back he's getting his weapons back that
would have been scary I'm gonna
understand everybody knows that that
would have been scary for the Niners
last week if Keenan Allen and Mike
Williams was out there I'll tell like we
the Niners were on our on our heels in
the third quarter if he would have had
some weapons so they're getting their
weapons back I like that Chef I really
like I really like your place today
brother that's a five-legged parlay in
my opinion it's probably like probably
better singles though better singles you
you're definitely gonna win more than
you lose in my opinion but we got one
more Sam we got one more one more pick
45 seconds is already up there
take it away bro all right I do think
this is probably the pick that's going
to be controversial and I am going to
lose the chat with but I'm taking the
Falcons minus two and a half look Justin
Fields is on an absolute mission right
now he is playing unbelievable football
but the rest of that team still stinks
and I think you even like case in point
last week like he was unbelievable last
week and they still lost at home to the
lions like the rest of that roster
especially with some of the trades is
just not very good
um I think that that defense is
particularly bad and the Falcons are
going to control this game on the ground
so I think a really short spread
um is really appealing to me and again I
Like to Buy Low on these spots and the
Falcons obviously played very poorly
against Carolina
but in this league when you think a team
is down they usually bounce back and
that's why it's generally speaking so
unpredictable but I actually think it
can work into your favor if you expect
it so I like the Falcons here
Sam's rocking with the Falcons uh hey I
don't dislike it bro I don't dislike it
let's bring producer Ryan in here
because producer Ryan connects us to the
chat we gave them six Sam gave him six
he gave him six picks
what are they talking about in the in
the chat are they vibing not vibing
well there are some that are talking
about the Chargers pick and there are
some that are still hung up on the
Cowboys pick uh Drew sather says BR
keeps betting against the Vikings and it
never pays off it's gonna have to I
don't think I don't think I bet against
the Vikings one time on the show to be
completely honest I don't think I've
ever maybe no I bet on them sorry I bet
on them against the commanders and I
pushed so I'm oh and one on the Vikings
this year so
okay sorry my take though is always it's
gonna have to it's gonna have to zag at
one point where's zigging it's gonna
have to zag uh Jacob says Chargers plus
five and a half is a lock so he's riding
with you there s Riley Chargers getting
healthy he likes it
um we've got Killer Queen saying Sam you
are the truth uh and our Bobby wants to
know because he saw Drew sather's
comment and he wants to know if we have
the stats on our win loss record
I don't know if we do
no yeah we we probably do we'll get the
producer to give us okay it's good it's
a winning record
at the end of the day just know whoever
that commenter was we are up we are up
and that's going to lead me to this next
segment that's going to lead me to this
next segment because I'm going to boost
it anytime TouchDown for you guys
because we're up but I need you guys to
get in the chat and tell me what you
want boosted Ryan pull up those odds for
us please brother
let's get to it let's get to it I love I
love the anytime TD ads this week uh
first up saquon Barkley the most bet
player today minus 200 I'm in New York I
passed by MetLife Stadium on my way to
the office it's cold as hell guys cold
and windy they're gonna run run run the
ball I like that uh Nick Chubb back uh
under a dome this week in Detroit minus
140 Jonathan Taylor mine minus 135
against the Philadelphia Eagles Justin
Fields who everyone is betting everyone
loves shots that feels the hottest man
alive right now plus one tend to score a
touchdown then we've got Joe Mixon or
Madre Stevenson Stefan Diggs and AJ
Brown to round out our top eight like
Greg said drop your locks in the chat
we're boosting one of these so let us
know who you like today
let us know who you like uh Ryan like
let's get into the chat who does the
people like let's talk about it yeah so
we've got sonoa saying uh Travis Kelsey
TD I mean everyone on that Chief's
offense is hurt so I I don't I don't
disagree with that take uh trig away
saying Mark Andrews and Miles Sanders uh
I want to win wants to see that saquan
boosted to even money uh I don't blame
you they will run the ball a lot today
uh jackham Nick Chubb anytime TD
um
and then we've got sonoa saying Fields
always getting in the end zone
so and then we've got and then there it
goes and then we've got Sox dude saying
Fields Zibby saying Fields give me give
me give me uh Tiger King says feel
like I said everyone's betting Justin
Fields right now there's nobody hotter
than Justin fields on the market at the
current moment and he's Plus 110. I mean
if we could boost that that would be
wonderful yeah so I'm I'm I'm I'm my
like my lights you know all over the
place right now but I'm getting right
but I need to know we we want to know
which way are we we which way are we
leaning man which which way are we going
what's the Vibes talking about how are
we feeling like
I'm trying to boost this for the people
so talk to me and talk to me once Ryan
mentioned Justin Fields there have been
90 000 comments in the chat saying
Justin Fields yeah yeah and he's plus
money I mean like I said if we could
boost an already plus money play uh I
will be I will be drooling over that all
right there it is I guess those are the
Vibes that we are going with Justin
Fields Justin Fields that's who we are
riding with I'm about to do my magic I'm
about to do my magic we're gonna boost
Justin fields from plus 110 to plus
150 plus 150 oh that is Juicy uh Sam
talk to me who do you like to get in the
end zone today
um I'm gonna go with my guy Jonathan
Taylor I'm you know I'm on the Colts
like I said I think they're the Eagles
run defense is really suspect I think
they're going to run the ball a lot so
I'm taking Johnny Taylor baby
Jonathan Taylor make sure you guys tell
us on DraftKings so you guys can get
rich your selves uh keep dropping your
picks in the chat but it's time for
Greg's pick because I'm gonna give you
guys my favorite play today actually
it's a question it's a question I'm
asking you guys is this something that
you would put your money on but it's
very very enticing Ryan please pull up
that bet that we were talking about
earlier please pull it up because I
gotta talk to the people I Wanna Know
you guys think Justin Jefferson
plus Devante Adams
to get 300 plus receiving yards combined
today sit in that plus 1200 Sam I saw
your face I saw that face that you made
but listen look at this though Devonte
Adams East in the lineup today he had
won 26 last week Justin Jefferson in the
lineup today he had
193 last week and I'm talking about
receiving yards I'm talking about
receiving yards both of them are helping
I think that it's going to be a shootout
with the Vikings I think that they're
going to be in the shootout situation I
think that Devonte Adams is going to
have to get the the Raiders going I
think he's going to put it on himself to
get the Raiders going so a lot of
targets to Devonte a lot of targets to
JJ
300 total yards sitting at plus 1200
plus 1200 for a reason all you got to do
is put 50 down you can vote Sam
talk to me Ryan talk to me I'm asking is
this a good bet or is it not
I just I just love Greg you just Swank
with the fences man seriously you could
come on here and you could just give
like a minus 110 bet but you know and no
you you swing with the fences you know
that people are gonna say oh no way it
cashes Greg never wins you you go
through that you you take the step past
that and you ride with what you believe
in so I love it I look I think those
who's more fun to bet on than those two
guys I agree with you I do think both
those guys are gonna get a ton of yards
today
um especially Jefferson I do think I
agree I think it's going to be a
shootout so 1200 sprinkle a few bucks on
it I mean you're you're kind of hot you
know quietly everyone says Greg never
wins
the real ones know the real ones know
but uh Ryan talk to me talk about the
chat tell me what they're talking about
hey we're just looking for Scoops we're
just looking for Scoops plus 1200
Chester Jefferson in a shootout Devonte
Adams putting a team on his back there's
gonna be a lot of targets I'll tell you
that there's gonna be a lot of targets
with these two yards they usually come
with targets I'm asking I'm asking is
this Allah
uh I you know how I feel Greg
um Justin Jefferson is taking a trip to
Diggs Island today but luckily for you
Devonte Adams may may get to 300 yards
by himself uh our buddy Mike Ritter
seems to think the same as me against
Pats retain and Diggs with a ton of
question marks
um
yes do we not see what the rookie did
last week against those same DBS
the rookie Watson from Green Bay carved
those DBS up I mean digs last year like
let's talk about last year coverage wise
mediocre he did he did have a lot of a
lot of interceptions I'll give him that
but coverage wise
mediocre JJ JJ's gonna ball in my
opinion my bad for cutting you all
producer Ryan but I had to I had to talk
to my boy Michael later because JJ's
gonna vote yeah I know it's good you got
to fit your propaganda in there I mean I
have to too but Trayvon takes it's the
truth that's all I got to say uh the
onion says uh great picks Greg uh
Michael Ribeiro jumping in the chest my
brother saying Trayvon Diggs deserves
more respect you've really now you've
ignited the flame in the riberos and
that's tough uh
let's see uh Cranston Gordon says uh
agreed ton of targets death not a lock
for 300 but it'll be close
so hey hey that's all we want is a bet
that we have action on you know plus
1200 sprinkle it I'm not telling you
guys to go put five thousand dollars on
it sprinkle this ride it there's gonna
be a ton of targets tons of targets
possibly walk home with some money
tonight uh but sorry to your brother
sorry to you Ryan it's the Cowboys
apologize to the Cowboys faithful not
just you know I don't know if I don't
know if he has an island he probably has
like a peninsula maybe maybe a peninsula
or something but an island I just don't
know if he's like isolated out there you
know I was like I don't he could he he
he's definitely has the interception
numbers last year but Island I don't
know I will I will say the chat does
like sonoa says if Diggs doesn't follow
JJ uh all night I think he has a big
game so like there are people who are
like if he's guarded by Anthony Brown
and Kelvin Joseph on someplace he he
will go off so it's not a guarantee I
mean Trayvon Diggs is not like a shadow
your best receiver guy so it could
happen
we're talking about JJ Justin Jefferson
one of the I mean I have them on my
fantasy team he's absolutely killing for
me but I mean he's one of the best
receivers in the game I think he is the
best receiver in the game so it doesn't
matter who's lying up against him in my
opinion yeah
my man is going to get his but Ryan it's
time it's let's move on let's move on we
didn't talk about this enough uh it's
time to grade some bets yes it's time to
Grace the best it's time to drop your
locks in the chat me and Sam we're going
to grade your bets Ryan talk to us
what do the people like
all right so the onions jumped back in
here and said grade this pick Tyler
higbee plus 285 anytime touchdown with
Cup being out now let me just say this
real quick I love the fact that he
dropped the odds in here making me let's
do work we've requested this for the
longest time so thank you but uh yes
kudos
can we send them a t-shirt for that
because we have to set an example we
have to set an example if you guys are
dropping your takes please send us odds
so we can uh grade your picks but Sam
can we send that guy a t-shirt can we
send that in a t-shirt 100
audience you're getting a t-shirt
I I like that pick I mean like it's got
to be a ton of redstone targets freed up
without cups Stafford's back I I really
don't have an issue with that I'll give
that I'll give that a b because
obviously like I said I don't give A's
unless you're exactly picking what I'm
picking so that's a big thing Sam you're
hilarious I like that pick too I think
uh the ball's gonna be spread around
spread around without
uh so it has some chances sprinkle it
number two close yeah I'm gonna say yeah
it's plus two whatever Ryan said but
it's up there so plus 280. yeah uh a
Eddie CD Lam anytime touchdown
and and because on the side that I'm on
and uh I think Greg's gonna be in two
because Greg the shootout angle I like
it I like it shoot up CD's gonna get in
there I I think the ball is going to be
up and down up and down in that game so
uh I like it I'll get I'll give that a b
all right uh zippy
saying forget about we don't need the
points with the Jets we don't need them
take your points take them back we're
taking the money line Jets money line in
Foxboro today
what do you all right I think you should
grade that bet because you have money on
this game so why don't you take it away
uh I have Jets plus three and a half
listen I took the points because it's
like you know all I need them to do is
lose by a field goal but I really love
the Jets today I really love the Jet Set
I will give this I will give this a B
plus only because I took the points uh
if it was an a I would have taken the
money line but I like I would give that
a B plus
there it is there there it is I mean you
took it away you might as well just move
on from there yeah I'm also an easier
greater than you guys you guys are my
entire class is on a curve you know what
I mean everyone's getting eight it's
just it's just love uh all right let's
see we've got
uh
uh Paul saying Jonathan Taylor 90 plus
rushing yards
I like it they're gonna they are going
to attack that Eagles Rush defense at
home they're they're not gonna put this
game in Matt Ryan's hands
um and again we saw what the commanders
did to that Eagles Rush defense last
week I don't think that you know the two
three hundred Pounders at the Eagles
signed four days ago are really going to
make a massive difference I think they
need uh at least right away I think they
need those guys to get some time in and
Jordan Davis back up before that defense
gets back in a good place
I think uh Jeff Saturday he's an
offensive lineman you know former
offensive lineman I think he's
established in a physical presence in
Indianapolis he's trying to get them to
play physical they have a great running
back we all know Jonathan Taylor is a
really good running back
so can he go over today uh I I think so
yeah I think that they're gonna have
he's going to have the ball in his hands
a lot and and men and I'm back to
mentioning Jeff Saturday in that
offensive line you know uh mindset that
he has and that physicality mindset I
think that uh the ball is going to be in
his hands a lot he's going to get a lot
of touches to go over that number
okay uh
that's easy Bears team total over 23
minus 115. he added he added the minus
115 I like that I appreciate it I like
it
uh no I do think there are gonna be a
lot of points scored in that game I
think both those defenses are are pretty
horrendous
um so I I don't dislike it at all but I
hope it goes under by about 23 points
okay okay uh sonoa Josh Allen over one
and a half passing TDS in a dome with a
bunch of question marks
that's easy hey I mean yeah the odds
have got to be what like minus 250 but
yeah it would have been nice if he
included the odds but you know no
T-shirt for him I'll take him our Aid
back that's a d
[Laughter]
it's oh oh it's minus 225. yeah I was
close I said 250. roughly did yeah
sprinkling not just kidding
hey Ryan we got two more two more and
let's get up out of here
all right
um let's see no disrespect but what I
love that username I love that's a
username that's not even a comment no
disrespect but Steelers moneyline
I like it I mean I like the value there
again I'm I'm soft so I'll always take
the points when when the bookmakers give
me points I will take them
um but I do think that's gonna be a
really really close game and again it's
a spot the Steelers have traditionally
crushed in and I just think that defense
is just a whole different animal with
lot back so I like it
with all due respect I like the pick
Steelers at home we talked about it
earlier in the show uh but am I betting
the money line I don't think so I'll
take the points just like Sam just
mentioned uh but since it's a respect
Factor I'm gonna give my guy a b
because uh it's with all due respect
okay we're gonna try and get them I'm
gonna try and get him today here uh
I like this comment I like this pick
Reasonable Doubt
Brian Robinson
over 64 and a half rushing yards minus
145 against that leaky Houston Texans
defense
yeah yeah I mean that Rush defense is so
bad that like historically bad but I
will say outside of that Eagles game the
commanders really have not been able to
run the ball that well I will say real
quick the line right in front of my face
just dropped to 62 and a half
never a good sign no no no no no
this may be an F
yeah you know what I want to say
I just feel like this needs to be
mentioned I know we're right at time
there's a ton of love for Tommy Trimble
anytime TD in the comments and I'm very
very confused by that so I just want to
mention that got one target last week
and I'm just like looking at his page
right now two receptions like he just
doesn't get a lot of look so so someone
is taking a shot of their Tommy Trimble
plus 600 at any time TD and uh if it
cashes we will salute you because that
is that is a risky bet it's plus 600 or
1600. I thought it was I mean he was
dropping plus 600 but
um I'll give it a look yeah yeah that
might be a scoop fellas that might I
just feel like it needed to be mentioned
because I love when people throw out
crazy bets like that so hey let's in on
those vibes Sam let's end on those vibes
you guys got the six Best Bets from my
man Sam Richmond you are you guys also
got uh a question that I post Devante
Adams Justin Jefferson 300 plus yards
receiving combined sitting at plus 1200
is not a good bet my man producer Ryan
been connecting us to the chat all show
um and he also dropped some takes he he
likes the Cowboys and he loves the Jets
he loves the Cowboys love the chats so
he's not only connecting us to the chat
he's also dropping the Scoops but we
we gotta go man we gotta go bet these
games we gotta go watch these games we
gotta get up out of here so we'll see
y'all next week peace
[Music]
[Applause]
yeah yeah
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]